(groovy music)
- Well, Mrs. Claus
makes the best pancakes.
- Wait. I thought you
guys only eat cookies.
- Oh, we eat more than just cookies.
(Santas laughing)
- Can't you tell?
(jolly Christmas music)
(Santas laughing)
- Ho, ho, ho! Merry Christmas!
- Merry Christmas!
- Hey, Santa!
- Hey, Santa.
(jolly Christmas music)
- Hello, I'm Santa Claus.
You can find me at the North Pole.
- Ho, ho, ho! I'm Santa Claus.
- I'm Santa David,
and you can find me at the North Pole.
- Ho, ho, ho! I'm Santa Curtis,
- Santa Chuck.
- Each Santa has their own belly laugh.
(Santas laughing)
- One at a time. Chuck first.
(Santa Chuck ho-ho-ho's)
(Santa Joseph ho-ho-ho's)
(Santa Clifford ho-ho-ho's)
(Santa David ho-ho-ho's)
(Santa Curtis ho-ho-ho's)
- I say beards.
- Beards?
- Real nice, long, thick
beards are priority.
- [Santa David] Which ya have.
- We all have 'em!
- [Santa David] We all have 'em.
- Don't forget the physique.
- The physique!
(Santas all talking at once)
- Mrs. Claus has had me on a
diet for the last few seasons.
- She has me on one
too. It's a new cookie.
It's called paleo.
- Santa Claus is no stranger to dieting.
(Santas laughing)
- I like just ordinary
chocolate chip cookies.
- I like snickerdoodles.
- Okay. I'll do snicker doodles.
- [Santa David] Do a fist
bump there, Santa? You too?
- How about costumes?
- I don't wear a costume.
I wear a very nice suit.
- I like the vest Mrs.
Claus made you, that...
- Oh, it's mint green.
- [Santa Clifford] Nice!
- And you know, I asked my elves
to get me a candy cane in my suit
and they just gave me a little candy cane.
I said, "Well, I wanna Santa size."
So they got me this, okay?
And this is in the pocket of my suit
wherever I go.
I carry a nine foot candy cane.
(Santas laughing)
- That's enough to keep me in snacks
for a couple of hours.
(Santas all talking at once)
- [Santa David] Yeah. Yeah.
- I really like that buckle, Santa.
- [Santa David] That
is a beautiful buckle.
- I think it sort of goes
along with my magic key.
- [Santa David] That's a magic key.
I've seen a bunch of them.
You know, we get asked this.
A lot of children live
where there's no chimney.
Well, Santa has a magic key
and can walk right in the front door.
(Santa Curtis ho-ho-ho's)
- [Director] What are the hardest requests
you've had to hear for Christmas presents?
- Actually, I've got one.
I was asked if I would donate my kidney
to this young girl's aunt.
I have a book I keep with prayers in it
and I wrote her name down and I told her
that I'd talk to God for her to see
if we could help get at her aunt a kidney.
That was probably the hardest
one I've ever had to do.
- Hmm, I think the hardest one I had
was a little girl asked for her dad.
- Yeah. Oh yeah.
- Yeah.
- Dad was deployed to
the desert at the time.
- A little child, probably
five or six years old,
and the dad was incarcerated at the time.
She wanted to know if
Santa could make sure
he'd be home for Christmas.
- Mmm.
- [Santa Clifford] Wow.
- What'd you tell her, Santa?
- "Santa will see what he can do."
- Yes!
- [Santa David] Santa
will see what he can do.
- Yeah.
- Last year I had a 12 year old girl
who had just given her kidney
to her eight year old sister.
That was a very touching
virtual phone call
with the grandparents there too.
But the toughest for me personally
was trying to fit a unicorn into my sack.
One, they don't fit.
And two, they poop rainbows.
No live animals in Santa's sleigh.
- I had a kid who wanted a live Panda.
I had to explain that it
was an endangered species.
- [Santa Joseph] Well, you know,
I'm gonna make it easy for you guys.
I'm just gonna take
the last spot over here
because Santa's been losing his belly
and every year I get nasty teenagers
saying I'm the skinny Santa.
So I'm voluntarily putting myself here
thanks to that keto cookie.
- I think he's got the best beard.
(Santas laughing)
- 'Cause it's all white and snowy.
- When it comes to
outfits, I have to admit,
I like yours as number one.
I put you to the front of the line, sir.
- I'm with that down.
Come down to the front of the line.
(Santas laughing)
- I think, actually, I'd accept this
just the way it is.
- [Santa Clifford] All right.
- That was easy.
- [Santa Clifford] Consensus already?
- Well, because they bring children in
and the children make the decision
in the Santa game.
- They're the important ones.
- [Santa Curtis] They're
the ones we gotta listen to.
I think that's probably one
of the biggest qualities
of Santa is we actually
listen to the children,
hear what they're saying to us,
and actually respond to 'em.
- My friend, there is no greater job
in the whole world than the one we have.
- I absolutely agree.
Yep.
(Santa Joseph ho-ho-ho's)
- I think there's kids!
- Our first child.
(Santas all laughing together)
- [Santa Joseph] Merry Christmas!
(Santas continue laughing)
- [Santa David] You're wearing me.
I'm a Santa shirt.
- Hi, Santa. Can I take a picture?
- [Santa David] Sure!
- [Santa Joseph] Yeah!
(Santas laughing together)
- [Santa Curtis] Merry Christmas!
- So, you have any questions for us?
- Yeah.
Where's Rudolph?
- Rudolph right now is with the rest
of the reindeer at a secret reindeer farm.
They're gettin' ready to
start training for Christmas.
- Oh.
- What gender is all your reindeers?.
- All the reindeers we
have right now are boys.
There's a lot of girl
reindeers that wanna get
in the race though, if you ask me.
- But I heard all of the
reindeers who are female.
- Oh.
- [Santa Chuck] No.
- [Santa Clifford] No.
- Dasher is a boy.
Dancer is a girl.
- So is vixen
- Vixen is a girl too.
- What about Donner?
- Donner is a boy.
- Boy.
- Where's the North Pole?
- Way up at the top of the world.
- [Santa David] That way!
- Oh.
- What are all your elf's names?
- There's 700,956 elves?
- [Santa Chuck] Wow.
- [Little Girl] Okay, but
maybe just a few of them.
- Jingle, Susie, Lamont.
- Pixie, Dixie, Gunther.
- Olaf makes the best cupcakes, I think.
- Wait, I thought you
guys only eat cookies.
- Oh, we eat more
- than just cookies.
- We eat more than cookies!
(Santas laughing together)
- [Santa Chuck] Can't you tell?
- What questions do you have for us?
- No questions, but I'm gonna try to guess
which one are you the real Santa.
- Yes!
- Okay.
- Oh, yes.
- I think you're the real Santa.
- Me?
- Yeah.
- Cutting to the quick!
- [Director] You're right!
- [Santa David] Yes!
Real Santa!
- [Santa Chuck] Very good, very good!
- I think he's the real Santa Claus.
(Santa Clifford ho-ho-ho's)
- [Santa David] Good job!
- [Santa Curtis] You got it right!
- [Santa David] Gettin' it
right! (Santas all cheering)
- I think the one that's the real Santa
is...
you.
- [Director] You got it!
- I did?
- [Santa David] Wonderful! Wonderful!
Excellent! Yes.
- Ho, ho, ho!
- Hi!
That's so cool.
- It's very nice meeting
you and talking with you.
So have you started working
on your Christmas list yet?
- Actually, no.
- No?
Do you have an idea of maybe
the top two things that you might want?
- Hmm.
- So what would you like for Christmas?
- I would like a, a Lego set.
- Oh! Those are so much fun.
- What do you want for
Christmas this year?
- A toy?
- Any old kind of toy?
- I don't want a old one.
(Santas all laughing)
- The answer would be new toys.
- I like that one.
- But why didn't I see any letters,
last year's Christmas,
there wasn't any presents
that said Santa on it.
- You know, I'll have to talk to the elves
'cause they're the ones
that package everything
up and put all the labels and all that
on there, you know?
So, I don't know what happened last year
because with COVID and all that,
it was such a wild and crazy year.
So I'll talk to them when I get home.
- Okay.
- Okay?
- [Little Girl] One other
thing, how old are you?
- How old am I?
- Yeah.
- Well, I'm the same age as my tongue
and older than my back teeth.
- Huh?
(Santas laughing)
- I'm really old.
You being good?
- Yeah.
- Helping out mom and dad and all that?
Doing your chores?
- Yes.
- [Santa Clifford] Yeah.
- [Santa Joseph] Good.
- Any other questions?
- Uh-uh.
- Okay. You have a good day, okay?
Buh-bye!
- [Santa Joseph] Ho, ho, ho!
- [Santa David] Merry Christmas!
- Like. Comment.
- And subscribe.
- Comment, like, subscribe.
- And make sure to ring the bell
so you get a notification whenever
there's a new episode.
- Ho, ho, ho, ho!
- Merry Christmas!
(Santas all ho-ho-hoing)